since it premiered on an obscure
Canadian cable channel in 2001 Trailer
Park Boys has gone from an underground
cult favorite to an international
sensation as audiences around the world
warm to the foul-mouthed antics of Ricky
Julian and bubbles but how much do you
really know about the people behind the
show his look at the untold truth of
Trailer Park Boys almost nobody was
professional instead of professional
actors many of the original cast were
friends of creator Mike Clattenburg Rob
Wells and John Paul Tremblay who play
Ricky and Julian met Clattenburg in high
school and went on to run a pub and
pizzeria on Prince Edward Island before
leaving to work on the show another of
Clanton Burke's buddies was Mike Smith
who was so funny when he visited the set
to record some audio tracks that they
added into the cast as bubbles John
Dunsworth who plays Jim Lahey had the
most experience out of the original cast
having worked steadily as an actor since
the 1960s while j-roc actor Jonathan
Torrance also had some experience as the
host of a teen oriented talk show called
Jonah Bishop close call after an early
career as a local TV producer in Halifax
Nova Scotia Clattenburg shot a
feature-length Trailer Park Boys pilot
on his own dime in 2000 he flew to
Toronto to pitch the show to TV
executives unfortunately a mockumentary
about a group of foul-mouthed petty
criminals wasn't an easy sell every
network gave him a firm 9 Clattenburg
had actually given up and was preparing
to return to Nova Scotia when he decided
to give it one more shot
he and producer Barrie done cold calls
showcase a relatively new cable channel
that was still trying to find its niche
to their shock the Vice President of
Programming picked up the phone and they
were in her office pitching the show in
25 minutes
shark ace loved the pilot and the
Trailer Park Boys series was given the
greenlight slow-burn Trailer Park Boys
debuted on showcase in 2001 but it
didn't exactly set the work alight in
its first season Michael Jackson who
played Trevor says that one early fan
organized the party to celebrate the
show and the whole cast decided to
unfortunately no one else showed up and
the cast spent the night partying with
the one fan fortunately showcase was a
struggling young channel in need of
content and played the episodes on
repeat until they picked up a cult
following across North America when the
cast visited Los Angeles in 2004 they
were shocked to find everyone knew who
they were despite the fact that the show
had never aired in the u.s. sounds like
they really turned up the heat mark free
the cost of Trailer Park Boys are known
for their love of booze and weight even
signing a deal to have their own brand
of marijuana one thing they don't do
though is actually smoke or drink
on-camera for smoking scenes rob Wells
has said that they're often actually
choking on rosemary and the pot plants
grown by Ricci are actually perfectly
legal industrial hemp plants which do
not contain any THC that said you can
spot real cannabis at least once in the
series with Wells explaining that there
was one time when we were doing bottle
hits they were trying to get this fake
stuff to burn my cache and they couldn't
find anything that worked so I think
they used real hash for that one but was
lifted all the way from California baby
one last shot a major inspiration for
the series was a short film Clattenburg
made in 1998 the short called one last
shot featured John Paul Tremblay and Rob
wells as early versions of Julian and
Ricky the film was entirely improvised
on set and John Dunsworth apparently
stole the show in his first appearance
as mr. lahey to the point that he nabbed
a best performance award at the Atlantic
Film Festival sadly one last shot has
never been commercially released old
lady glasses Mike Smith's bubbles
quickly became the show's breakout
character with his friendly attitude
complemented by a pair of adorably thick
glasses which are actually older than
the character in fact his girlfriend
found them at an estate sale in Texas
for 50 Cent's among the effects of a
recently deceased old lady Smith loved
glasses and would put them on to amuse
friends which was the origin of the
bubbles character the glasses originally
gave him a pounding headache but over
the years his eyes have adjusted to the
ridiculous prescription angry actors
after six seasons the actors who played
Corey and Trevor left the show
complaining of low pay and poor working
conditions gory bolts eventually
returned as quarried but Michael Jackson
refused to make another appearance as
Trevor posting that he felt ripped off
and quote disrespected as an actor and
as a person according to Jackson he
worked for the minimum Actors Equity pay
for the first three seasons then
received only tiny raises despite the
show's growing popularity by season five
friends who appeared in commercials were
still making more than he was to make
matters worse he said that the producers
repeatedly lied to him and the other
actors about other actors pay refused to
hire a proper film crew and provided
unsanitary bathrooms and trailers John
Paul Tremblay later hit back at Jackson
on a trailer park boys forum claiming
that any difference in pay was due to
the fact that the primary cast members
also worked as full-time writers on the
show for what worked out to pennies on
the hour abuse accusations fans loved
bubbles for his gentle childlike nature
so they were shocked in 2016 when Mike
Smith was arrested in a Los Angeles
hotel and charged with domestic battery
against a woman named Georgia Ling but
the charges were quickly dropped with
Ling releasing a statement saying at no
point did I feel I was in danger
otherwise I would have called the police
myself which I did not the police were
called by others not present in the room
who mistakenly perceived the argument to
be something other than what it was
actress Lucy Dakota who plays Lucy
further muddied the waters when she
announced she was leaving the show with
the tweet that read if I find out that
somebody is abusive I cut them out of my
life it's very easy
however the show's publicist
contradicted this statement insisting
that dekha tare had informed producers
she was quitting weeks earlier Deckert
air later tweeted the TPB cast and crew
are still my friends
there are no bad feelings between us
Burger Time during their recent live
tour the boys earned some extra cash by
having fans come up on stage to buy
hamburgers for $10 a pop at some shows
the burgers were cooked live on a George
Foreman grill
while at other shows they apparently
were just McDonald's cheeseburgers
wrapped in paper Feist later estimated
the julienne raked in at least $1,500 at
a show in Oakland with drunk and stoned
audience members queuing up on stage to
buy the burgers in an interview to
promote the UK leg of the tour John Paul
Tremblay insisted that the stunt wasn't
a scam those people got their
cheeseburgers it certainly could have
been worse it won't end any time soon
after over 10 seasons multiple movies
and international Live Tour and numerous
minisodes and specials the boys could be
forgiven for wanting to take a break as
the boys told Metro news it's funny to
watch the characters get older we're 20
years from now you see Ricky Julian and
bubbles who are in their late 60s we
want to continue shooting until our fans
say guys it's time to shut it down
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
you